GRZEGORZ KOSSAKOWSKI: Thanks
for introduction.
So I'm from University
of Warsaw.
I've been working here at Google
Atlanta for about three
months kind of changing projects
to make Scala in GWT
work better.
So first we chose to start with
a question why Scala in
GWT, why anybody would care?
So Scala brings a lot of
development techniques to Java
developers.
And it means five channel
programming, better improved
object orientation, we've tried
syntaxing composition.
And at the same time it works
very well with existing Java
libraries.
And on the bottom you can see
a teaser of what you achieve
do in Scala.
This is a real code snippet I've
taken from [INAUDIBLE]
of GWT.
So I didn't make it up.
It's real code.
And I will explain later on
what's the real difference,
what's happening on the
right-hand side and why you
get sharper code too.
It can read this.
So that's one reason to work on
integration with Scala in
GWT.
So the basic task is to
connect to compilers.
And this sounds challenging
but if you try to approach
this problem you immediately
see that both compilers are
working with abstract
syntax tree.
So you know the structures
these compilers are
processing.
And so essentially what you need
to translate from one AST
to another AST from Scala
internal AST to GWT internal
AST. But there is a problem
actually because with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
right?
It's like both projects don't
want to make AST as a part of
API.
They want compilers to evolve.
And if we would make a direct
approach of just writing code
that just translates from one
AST to another we would
introduce direct type collection
between these two
projects and it means all
hassle-- it introduces a
hassle like you have to
coordinate the review list,
you have to coordinate changes
in APIs and none of those
projects none of Scala
team are working with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on that.
And there is actually
interesting observation that
you had the situation right now
with JDT so Java support
in GWT is implemented in exactly
this way that you have
another JDT compiler in GWT and
you have translation from
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and JDT and structures to
GWT data structures.
But the difference is Java
is evolving much slower.
So if there is a change like a
new release of a compiler it's
like every few years and with
Scala it's every one year or
probably even more often.
So we need a loose connection,
right?
It's like still we want to
translate it from one data
structure to another but with
some loose connection.
So we need a stable API that
both projects can target.
And this is independent in some
way, some manner from
both projects.
And since we are working with
compilers it makes sense to
introduce another language.
Compilers are working
with languages.
So we can introduce
another language.
And the language we're
introducing during this summer
is called Jribble.
And this is our stable API.
Before I go into describing
how Jribble looks like and
details of Jribble, but first
we should answer a question:
But what about Java
source code?
This is a language which GWT
is supporting and why we
shouldn't just translate Scala
to Java and don't even bother
with GWT at all.
But there are serious problems
with this approach.
So the first bullet
is important.
I mean it would be so beneficial
to have direct
translation from
Scala to Java.
But if it was possible or if
it was easy then someone
already would implement it.
Right?
It would have already
been implemented.
And there were actually attempts
to do that in the
past. There are two examples--
very good examples-- where
translation is really
problematic.
One is that in Scala you have
unchecked exceptions -- all of
them.
So you can slow every exception
and you don't need
to declare this in your
message signature.
And as everybody knows you have
to declare exceptions you
are scaling in Java.
And you can imagine some kind
of program analytics that
tries to recover this
information-- which exceptions
you are throwing but
this would be hard.
It's a rather hard problem.
And the second problem, which is
even more serious, is that
constructor calls doesn't
follow Java rules.
And it means that you can't have
a super constructor call
as the first statement in
a definition of your
constructor.
OK?
And there is no way to work
around this issue.
It's kind of artificial Java
restriction which I believe
the motivation behind this rule
is to protect programmers
from making mistakes--
big mistakes.
But if it's a compiler which
generates these calls it
should be fine, right?
And the reason why you need
these calls is it's mixing
composition, I believe.
So you can try it and it keeps
mixing composition in Scala.
And this is really
serious problem.
So that's why this approach
didn't work.
But there in another common
language which is called Java
byte code.
And again everyone on Java
platform is targeting Java
byte code.
So what about this
as a stable API?
And it doesn't work either
because basically Java byte
code is very low level and it
doesn't carry structure of
your program.
So you can have an example of
an expression [INAUDIBLE]
and nested expression and it's
being translated to a list of
very simple operations.
And we need this structure
in GWT.
GWT realize when doing
optimization and translating
programs into complex
Java script.
It just relies on having
this structure.
And another problem is arbitrary
control flow which
is found in bytecode.
Which means you have goto
instructions everywhere.
That's how many things are
implemented in bytecode.
Again, you don't even have
anything which is
corresponding to goto
in JavaScript.
So we'd need to emulate it and
the result would be horrible.
You could imagine that maybe
you could try to recover
original structure of the
bytecode so you essentially
are doing the compilation.
But again, Java bytecode
is for [? years ?]
in the market and there is no
single decompiler which is
really successful.
So it means it probably is
impossible to do for every
case.
So that's motivation why
we introduced Jribble.
Jribble is Java derived
language.
So we basically start with
Java and we remove or add
things we need to make
tasks simplier.
Yeah there is really a funny
quote from Lex Spoon.
You should read that.
Jribble removes package
declarations and imports,
default constructors, for loops,
and restrictions on
calling super constructors--
the thing that I mentioned
before.
And Jribble adds method and
field signatures when you
reference them.
For example when you want to
call a method, you give the
whole signature including
L types.
And this is needed because we
want to know exact coordinate
of every method we are calling
without parsing and reading
all the files.
Again, so you should have a
method defined in other class
and I'm calling it
from other class.
On the call side, I want to know
exactly which method I'm
calling.
If you have a situation
with [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
methods for example, you don't
know which method you are
calling, right?
So you need the full signature
to know which methods you are
calling.
And yes, Jribble files are
verbose enough that they can
be parsed separately.
So you parse them in
an independent way.
So this is the architecture of
my project and the bottom
thing-- Java to gwtc-- it was
before I started doing--
hacking my stuff.
And I introduced the
fragment on top.
And it consists of two pieces so
you have a Jribble backend
on scalac side which means I
implemented new backend for
Scala compiler which instead of
generating Java bytecode it
generates Jribble.
OK?
And then on GWT side I
implemented a way to parse
these files in GWT with ASP
nodes out of these files.
And the thing in center is
the Jribble library.
So it basically-- it defines
Jribble language and it
defines a parser for Jribble
language and things like that.
So I thought it would be
beneficial for you to have an
idea how Jribble looks like, how
Jribble code looks like.
So as you can see it's
very verbose.
Like for everywhere you
reference or define a class
you have always fully
qualified reference.
We replaced dots with slashes
for references.
And you can see massive
signature in this line before
parameter list. So that's
how Jribble looks like.
And now I will go into more
details on each side: on Scala
side, Jribble side and GWT side,
what I was really doing
there.
So on the scalac side, it was
just another backend.
So Scala has JVM backend which
compiles Scala code into
bytecode.
And it has backend to target
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
bytecode which I don't
know status of.
And the nice thing about the
fact that this is another
backend is it's isolated from
the rest of the compiler.
So I'm not really messing with
internal parts of the
compiler.
It's like I'm just getting--
at the last phase of the
compiling I just plug in my new
backend and then I create
output in form of Jribble.
So that is important property
because if Scala compiler guys
are going to accept my code they
want to be sure that I
don't really mess up with
their own functionality.
I don't introduce new bugs
and things like that.
And this backend includes both
transformations and printing
of trees like abstract
syntax trees.
Which means I first meed to
normalize trees in a way that
they are more similar
to Java construct.
So for example in Scala
everything is an expression.
Like you can have-- like
block is an expresion.
If statements-- which is a
statement in Java, in Scala
it's an expression.
It's actually a nice replacement
for conditional
operator in Java.
So then you have to normalize
all these things so that they
are, again, become
an expression.
So this is the transformation
part.
And it really is simply
formatting the trees in the
form of Jribble.
And another thing I had to
implement was extending scalac
internal testing framework which
is called partest. They
have their own testing framework
and I had to add
support for Jribble.
And then the whole thing is
implemented in Scala which is
nice to work with.
And the challenges I faced on
scalac side is as I mentioned,
many expressions in Scala are
not expressions in Jribble.
So you have to really think
carefully how to translate
these constructs to valid
Jribble constructs.
And the second problem is
really, really difficult and I
don't have any good answer.
So that is pattern matching
logic which pattern matching
is very powerful in Scala.
But the internal implementation
can emit
arbitrary jumps.
So it means you have some form
of goto instruction that is
being used to implement pattern
matching-- and again,
I have the same problem.
I cannot emit goto expressions
in Jribble.
And I tried some tricks to
override goto into massive
calls and things like that but
I'm still not sure how
reliable this is and this can
lead to stack overflow, call
exceptions and things
like that.
So this is really
difficult part.
And Scala has unification of
types which means basically--
first of all, everything
is an object in Scala.
And there are two types which
are call Nothing and Unit.
Unit is similar to void in
Java but in Java it's not
really type because you cannot
have a variable of void.
And in Scala you can't have
a variable of type void.
And Nothing is probably-- OK,
if you know what is bottom
type than this is Nothing.
If you don't know I won't be
going into details because
it's like kind of-- you need
some time to explain it.
But my infestation of this
unification is the expression
in the bottom there.
You you see like that true
all-- and you have an
expression which is throwing
an exception.
And it has actually
type Nothing.
And another problem is our
operator both in Scala and
Java is likely overweighted.
OK?
So it doesn't throw an exception
because on the
left-hand side you have
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
so it doesn't really
right-hand side and it just
returns a result.
Translating it to Java or
Jribble needs some careful
thinking and attention.
It's really tricky part.
Actually I have still a lot of
bugs around this kind of
constructing in Jribble
backend.
So it's still not resolved
completely.
So that's all about
Scala side.
And there's Jribble side.
So Jribble consists of language
specification.
Right now the language
specification is only
implementation.
I didn't have separate
specification.
I plan to have one but I didn't
have time to define it.
And Jribble is a library.
So it defines AST nodes,
parsers, printers-- things you
usually want for a language.
And it's written in Scala which
was, again, fun to work
with.
And the last point is for
people interested in or
familiar with Scala.
I'm using Scala library
for parsing.
And you have an example of how
parse rules look like.
And this is just Scala code and
it's DSL, so it's a nice
library too.
And you still can read
what's happening.
It's a parser for parsing
while statement.
And I was actually very, very
happy when I was using this
library.
I think it's a really,
really good one.
Just to comment on that.
And there was actually an
interesting problem how to
test parsers.
Language like Jribble
is actually complex.
So if you look at the grammar,
it's complicated.
So then there is a challenge how
to really test parsers--
if it's parsing everything
correctly.
Like writing casual union
tests is really, really
tiring.
I don't know.
I would have to write hundreds
of union tests and then I'd
parse a fragment of source
code and I would need to
create all AST nodes by hanging
the code to check if
things are equal.
It's really, really tiring and
probably would give up after
10 tests.
So I decided to go
another road.
And if you think what
is a parser?
It's basically a function from
a string to AST node.
And you can define the printer
which goes in the opposite
direction.
It takes AST node and it
prints it to a string.
And you can compose
this to function.
So you take the parser-- sorry,
printer-- and then
parser and what you should get
is just a function of an AST
node, OK?
So once you have this
observation what you need is
lots of AST nodes.
Just to test the quality
of functions.
And I'm using ScalaCheck
framework to generate lots and
lots of AST nodes.
And using this approach I've
got more than 3,000 tests,
random tests, for parser.
And this approach turned out to
be very, very beneficial.
So I told myself many times
during the summer that I had
to refactor and change the
groundwork Jribble first of
all because I didn't think of
some special case or special
need.
So I had to refactor like half
of the grammar of Jribble and
as a consequence I had to
refactor the parsing code.
I wasn't really afraid of doing
that because I had so
many tests and they were
catching every mistake you can
imagine.
Random testing is very good
about boundary conditions that
you usually don't think of or
you are too lazy to really
test every boundary condition.
And usually there are bugs
really often waiting for you
for these boundary conditions.
So I really loved it.
And I was using Simple Build
Tool which is like a
replacement for [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
which is much, much for building
and running tests and
everything.
So Jribble challenges: Language
must encode a lot of
information.
So normally what you have, you
have a source code and
compiler is reading your source
code and once it has
the whole source code in memory,
it tries to recover
the information that is not
explicit in your source code.
So for example, if you are
calling a method, based on all
information it will calculate
coordinates of the message you
are really calling.
OK?
Because it's not really explicit
in source code which
methods you are trying
to call.
And there are many, many
other things like that.
Like you reference a field and
in the place where you
reference the field and you
don't have information of the
type of that field.
OK?
You have to go to the definition
of the field to see
the type and things like that.
So it's very, very verbose.
If you compile Scala's standard
library to Jribble
it's almost 60 megabytes
of Jribble output.
It's so huge.
But it compresses very well.
So you can go down to-- as far
as I can remember with
standard disk compression
to nine megabytes.
So it's so verbose
and so repeated.
And actually the most
significant reason for so huge
size is because we have fully
qualified references
everywhere, right, so you repeat
this information all
the time.
And grammar turned out to be
complicated enough to make
parsing challenging.
Which means it's almost like
Java with some things being
removed.
But I had similar problems that
people flagged when they
tried to parse Java.
And the last point is parser
combinators were invented by
functional programming
community.
And they are really,
really functional.
Basically the parsers are
constructed of lots of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
The problem with that is for a
lot of Scala code, if you're
compiling to bytecode, it maps
to-- like method calls are
being mapped to message calls.
And if you tried to used Java
tools for filing, you're fine.
You might get strange method
names because Scala compiler
is doing a method name
modeling sometimes.
But still you are fine.
But for highly functional code,
I tried profiling with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and the result was
really horrible.
I couldn't get any useful
information of the results
that's good.
Because what you really need
is to profile how much time
you spend on evaluating the
expression and not really
culling a method.
So you have complicated
expression and you would like
to know how much time you
spent on evaluating an
expression.
And Java profile's going to give
you that information and
my approach will probably
be to implement special
combinator for this parser
and use speechwriter.
So I guess it might be
interesting for you.
I looked into that problem and
it would be a good approach.
So now gwtc side.
On the GWT side I just plugged
my Jribble library in parallel
to JDT.
So it's like a parallel path.
And what I need to do is parse
Jribble files which is being
handled by Jribble library.
Parsing, everything is being
done by that library.
So I get AST nodes of Jribble
form and I need to translate
them to GWT AST nodes.
And Jribble is designed and
defined to be as close to Java
as possible, so translation
is usually very, very
straightforward.
Just take one AST node and
translation is basically
almost always one to one.
And the nice about this approach
is that, again, it's
isolated from the rest of gwtc
internal data structures and
functionality.
And yes, that was
the approach.
You define everything in Jribble
and you have as small
an impact on GWT as possible.
So again, I really tried to make
it focused so it can be
merged eventually to official
release I hope.
So GWT challenges: Obviously I
had to program in Java again.
And that was quite painful.
I don't like to go into
details but it is.
That's one point but another
point is you have really a lot
of these AST nodes.
Really, really a lot of them.
And every single set is
straightforward but due to the
large number of cases you'd
spend the entire day doing the
same thing which is tiring.
And especially if you realize
that you could do pattern
matching and you'd get 10 times
smaller code if you once
worked in Scala.
And so the third point is it's
kind of a complaint but I
don't say I have a better
answer to that.
So in terms of data structures
in GWT working in the way you
create like empty AST nodes and
then in second phase you
add more information.
And it's so easy to
miss something.
And sometimes at the very
beginning of my project I
missed a super-- I missed
filling in information about
interfaces a class implements
and I spent two days because
GWT compiler didn't blow
up or anything.
It would produce me
JavaScript code.
And then it's really fun to go
back in JavaScript code,
right?
So I spent two days to really
find I missed like one or two
lines of code just coding
this information.
And I don't know if there is
any good answer to that
problem but I'm not
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
like that.
A serious problem.
So right now I should present
something working I guess.
It's a good time.
And people from GWT team found
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
working I guess two
months ago.
And the funny thing is that I
still had [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
working and nothing else.
So after two months of work--
really, really hard work-- I
get only really, really
tiny improvements.
So I don't know if you guys
remember that and other people
watching cannot remember that.
But I had a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
finishing here before--
We can't see.
Oh, OK, sorry.
Now you can see?
Yep.
I think font size
could be bigger.
Ah very good.
Yeah that's better.
OK.
So the problem is I don't
see this on my screen.
OK.
Now I see.
So two months ago the only
difference between this demo
and the demo I presented two
months was that I had
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
class to finish here
for defining
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
OK?
And the only progress I got
is implementing that
functionality on scalac side and
Jribble and gwtc side to
replace this with lambda
definition and with implicit
definition.
So what's happening for people
who are not familiar with
Scala is here I have the
lambda definition.
It says I don't care about
parameter because I didn't use
it on the right-hand side.
And so it's a function from
ClickEvent to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
or Unit.
So I'll pass a lambda
function here, OK?
To the bottom right obviously
a button expects-- oh, I
cannot see-- it expects
a ClickHandler.
So what I do-- and this is
usually defining in some
library router or something you
always reuse-- so you're
defining implicit convention
from function which goes from
ClickEvent to Unit-- and
remember Unit is like a void
in Java-- which returns
a ClickHandler.
And here you have this analysis
class definition with
a method and onClick will call
it the function you pass.
So basically Scala compiler
works in a way that if it sees
something that doesn't type
check-- that type doesn't
match-- then it tries to find
an implicit definition that
will make the inserts
compile, OK?
And this is what's happening
in this sample.
And this works.
So I can show you it
compiles hopefully.
[TYPING]
And while this is being done
I can tell you that this is
surprisingly hard
to get right.
Because you need to implement
static fields.
And actually I'm
cheating here.
It still looks like you take a
Scala library because it needs
Scala library which defines
functions and things like
that.
So it looks Scala library is
being compiled and I'm just
using Scala library and
everything worked.
I hit to manually remove some
things because surprisingly
enough Scala function
definitions depend on Scala
collections which I didn't
even realize.
And Scala collections use all
language features you can
imagine.
They are so advanced that they
simply use everything.
And yes, here we've got this
resolve compilation and it's
called example.
[TYPING]
OK.
And hopefully nothing
will break.
I click a button, I get
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
from Scala, right?
[APPLAUSE]
This is the only thing
I've done.
Like anything else more
sophisticated really is Scala
collection, OK?
You need a list or map or
something to get anything
done.
And then you pull in all the
collections from Scala and
this is-- so basically you
need 100% of all Scala
features to get anything
running.
And I will switch back to slides
and just comment more
on that.
So is there anything more?
There no gradual progress in
this project which is really,
really disappointing, OK?
It's been like two weeks and
there is nothing running
completely.
Oh, just a bunch
of unit tests.
And that's all.
And as you can see, two months
later I have almost nothing
better running in terms
of GWT applications.
And I already told that Scala
collections library exploits
every language feature.
So where are we at?
What is the picture
of this project?
And if we recall our diagram,
I've got most of things
implemented on the left-hand
side and in the center of this
diagram.
Which means I can compile
entire Scala library in
Jribble with some little bugs
that I am aware of.
But I know how to fix them.
Most of them I know
how to fix them.
And the result is that I can
parse 96% of Jribble files for
standard Scala library which
corresponds to more than 4,400
files.
So this is kind of
big achievement.
I told you that it exploits
almost all the language
features.
I've got 4% remaining.
And again, this is fun.
I've got 90% running quite
quickly and then next every
percent is like few
days of working.
OK, so for the 6% it was like
two weeks to get this.
And I would expect the 4% would
be like a month to get
done and correct.
Because it involves things which
are most complicated:
Unit, Nothing and pattern
matching logic.
And the missing part is the
right-hand side of this
diagram which is getting
everything, every possible
node translated.
And I thought this was easy but
I discovered last night
that I forgot that GWT doesn't
support entire Java library,
standard library, right?
So Scala library, standard
library, in a few places
depends on Java standard
library.
And now the only thing you
can do is write by hand
replacements of that
functionality.
It's the same way how GWT
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
in standard Java library.
And this is actually
a lot of work.
You have to go through every
file, check everything or
create a framework that would be
checking for you for things
that are not allowed in GWT.
Yeah, it's kind of
a lot of work.
To comment on the status of the
project, I believe that
two months of really good
engineering work would bring
you to Showcase it working but
still inefficient, maybe with
bugs, and definitely won't
support, only from code line.
OK?
So this is like two months of
engineering still missing.
So, I mentioned Showcase many
times so I think at the end of
my talk I would like to
go through quickly.
It's like a big application
showing lots of GWT features.
But it's complicated enough that
you could imagine that if
there was any point in this
project then Scala should
really shine.
OK?
And there was external
contribution to my project.
There was a person that started
translating Showcase
into Scala.
And we will go through that.
This is the fragment that I
presented at the beginning of
my talk.
And what is happening here is
you set up many options and
you repeat the same method call
all the time-- do I have
a laser thing?
Yes.
So what's happening is you call
a set of many options all
the time and the first parameter
and the last
parameter is the same.
The only thing that is changing
is the second
parameter, OK?
So it's kind of obvious that
this should be refactored in a
form that this repetition
is removed.
And with Java you
probably could.
You'd find another method.
But this is like nobody does
it because it's too
heavyweight.
So in Scala it's very natural.
What's happening is you define
a list of things you want to
pass through to method.
And then you say for each and--
you have these method
call.
But with second thing you could
underscore which means
you take every element of the
list and pass through to this
method, OK?
And that's how you get much more
readable code size and it
really explains things.
And another example-- yes,
I've already showed you
getting rid of anonymous classes
which are really
annoying Java problem
and everyone agrees.
If you have only single method
you have to implement then
it's really annoying to
have this definition.
So with implicit convergence,
you can easy get rid of that.
And you can see-- again, a
fragment of Showcase-- how it
looks like.
And the third example is that
Scala has built-in XML
support.
So you can have XML literals
mixed in freely with Java and
Scala code.
So instead of concatenating
strings which is bad for many
reasons, you have a
nice XML literal.
And this actually more
secure, right?
Because we all know problems
with concatenating strings.
So not only more concise and
it's better to read this code,
but it's more secure.
So this is like another really
obvious benefit.
And I believe that there
might be much more.
So this is something you can get
without defining GWT APIs
and with very little
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
module and everything
will be working.
But I believe if you create more
sophisticated wrappers
around GWT API you would
get even more benefits.
So what's the future
of this project?
And first of all dev
mode support.
I didn't look into
that at all.
It's like if you cannot have
your code running and compile
with the common line there is
no point in going into that.
So I didn't have time even
think about it too much.
So the obvious goal is to
get Showcase running.
It's big enough to really prove
that you've got nice,
decent coverage of features.
And the third point is profiling
and optimizing
Jribble parser.
Right now the parser is really,
really slow and it's
not because it's functional and
it adds some overhead but
because there is backtracking
that I couldn't identify.
It's horrible.
I mean six minutes to parse
Scala-- Jribble of Scala
standard library.
And if these three things are
being implemented and done, I
hope that merging extensions
with gwtc and scalac would be
possible.
And translating more samples to
Scala would be beneficial
too.
And at the end of my talk I
would like to thank a few
people.
So, Rob Heittman was the person
who was taking care of
infrastructure for me.
So we had our own center for
code review, which was
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and he was taking care of all
this stuff which was really
beneficial to me.
The second person, Aaron
Novstrup, he translated
Showcase into Scala and again,
I'm really, really thankful
for that because I didn't have
enough time to spend time on
that.
And obviously Lex Spoon for
hosting me, for answering 20
questions a day and being
patient enough.
And I'd like to thank this
company because it's not like
in every company you can work
on that kind of project.
And thanks for releasing so
much good software on open
source licenses.
I really appreciate it.
And at the end there are some
pointers to homepage, groups,
code review.
And do you have any questions?
What's the status of getting the
Jribble back into Scala?
I didn't talk to Scala people.
So I attended a conference
by Scala guys.
It was in April this year.
And I mentioned that I'd been
accepted as an intern in
Google.
And they seemed to be very
interested in the project.
But since then I didn't really
talk about merging that
because first you want
something running.
But I believe that shouldn't
be a problem given the fact
that I was really careful
to not touch anything.
It's really just adding a new
package-- like Scala package
with new code.
And there's almost no
modification on the rest of
the compiler.
So I hope this will
be accepted.
But this is just my opinion.
I didn't talk to
those guys yet.
Also, your build step: You first
run scalac with a output
to Jribble and then you run
gwtc with a different fran
reader instead of reading
the Java code?
Yes.
So actually on GWT side it can
read Java and Jribble files at
the same time.
And this very important so
you can have half of your
application implemented in Scala
and then this will be
compiled to Jribble.
And half of your application
will be implemented in Java
and this will work well.
So it's more like-- I'm
basically going through class
parts and I'm trying to find
files with Jribble extension
and then I fire up my own parser
and all my logic for
these files.
And Java files are being parsed
as they are right now
in GWT.
So it's just file
name extension?
Yes.
It's just file name extension.
Any other questions?
In your slide about the
difficulties of translating
from Scala to GWT AST, I was
curious at what level-- this
may be not a useful question but
I'm curious what level of
the Scala compiler you're
hooked in to.
Because I would assume there's a
more AST-like level and then
there's probably something
slightly lower level that's
more appropriate for generating
bytecode or
something like that?
Yes.
Actually the answer is
complicated because Scala
code-- so before it reaches
bytecode there is something
called ICODE in Scala.
So it has like normal AST nodes
then it translates it to
ICODE and only then
to bytecode.
First of all, still Jribble
backend is not only printing
stuff to Jribble.
It's really sophisticated
logic which translates
constructs which you cannot
represent in Java in the right
way to [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
constructs that can be
represented in Java.
So if you would like to hook
Scala compiler directly to GWT
then the question is where are
you going to put this logic,
right?
And the only sensible answer is
you really need to do all
this work in Scala because
really this logic is
sophisticated and implementing
this in Java would be really,
really tiresome.
And then you need to add some
code to Scala compiler anyway.
And still Scala compiler is
evolving very quickly.
They really, really modify
their AST nodes.
So there would be a really big
problem in synchronization of
release and things like that.
And another benefit of having
Jribble is that other
languages can target it.
Like you can imagine a Ruby
compiler-- a JRuby compiler
for compiling in Jribble.
So I think from GWT point of
view it's much more beneficial
to have that kind of standard
language that everyone can
target.
So Jribble right now it
expresses mostly Java
constructs, sort of winnowing
it down to something useful
for this purpose.
If you made it more
representative of-- let's
assume for the sake of argument
that GWT AST had some
things in it like first class
functions and some of the
other constructs that you see
more of in Scala and that are
also directly representable
in JavaScripts.
Do you think that would make a
pretty big difference in the
quality of the compiled
output?
Like I fear, for example, lots
and lots of function literal
objects being created as classes
when in fact they're
much simpler and they're meant
to be much simpler
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
The answer is no because Scala
is fully object oriented so
even functions are objects which
means you have to really
represent them as classes, OK?
And so I don't really see
that much of benefit.
And the only benefit I could
see is like comma operator
which you have in JavaScript and
right now there is nothing
corresponding in Jribble.
So that would beneficial for
some cases but otherwise no.
There is no reason.
So Scala relies on JVM
optimizations and I guess for
things like [? anonymous ?]
classes we could rely on GWT
compiler optimizations to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
resulting JavaScript, and not to
make the intermediate form
have those optimization
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Yeah so yeah that's true.
So for example this implicit
comparison is a good example.
So you have a lambda which
is really a class.
In the class you have
lambda definition.
It's only one method which in
Scala is called apply and it
has the code that you
put in lambda.
And then you have another
wrapper which takes lambda and
creates like three
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK?
So it would be very, very
space forward for a good
compiler to inline all the whole
thing directly into an
anonymous class implementing and
then keep the lambda thing
completely.
And you'd still have the
lambda in your code but
compiler to easily
optimize it.
This is just inlining.
But this is obviously only in
special cases when you don't
rely on that fact that lambda
is really a class and you do
something more about it.
If you just take it and execute
it then you can
optimize it away.
And probably most of the time
that would be the case.
Any questions?
Maybe questions for
[? Visit? ?]
So you were saying, and if I
misheard you just tell me, but
you said that 96% of the Scala
standard library you could
translate.
Were you saying that from
basically translating that
into Jribble.
Is that what you refer to?
Yes.
So it's still- it's not like
GWT can handle that.
The reason why it cannot
handle that is, as I
mentioned, I have representation
in Jribble but
it still refers to Java
standard library, OK?
So the missing part is emulate
all these codes somehow.
And this is not very
difficult.
It doesn't require any compiler
knowledge actually.
It's more like you have to go
through all cases and think of
I don't know-- you have three
line method in Scala so you'd
have to replace it with
something that you have in
GWT.
So things like that.
It's actually converting all of
Scala standard library into
Jribble.
He's only parsing 92% of it.
OK, I see.
Anybody else?
So thanks for attention, for
coming, and thanks for hosting
me here in Atlanta and hopefully
see you in the
future.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]